le silence règne dans l'école erik satie
à montigny le bretonneux au fond du
couloir les clubs d'échecs des yvelines
se sont réunis pour s'affronter lors du
tournoi de la dame noire faire un niveau
relativement restreint mais on a des
jeunes et des joueurs pas forcément très
fort c'est des joueurs de clubs qui sont
licenciés mais pas forcément très fort
en gère l'espace dans une bonne ambiance
et c'est aussi ce que les gens
apprécient dans le tournoi les visages
sont fermés et concentré les joueurs
sont en pleine réflexion pour protéger
leur reine est effectuée au plus vite un
échec et mat à son adversaire
ma première partie c'est une victoire
j'ai joué contre une personne qui était
plutôt très agressive la partie était
serrée et puis par des petites erreurs
de l'adversaire ça m'a emmené
directement vers la victoire un pour moi
qui se veut conviviale et bon enfant
avec cette partie en quatre jours pour
les plus performants une remise de
chèque aura lieu à la fin du concours
erwan lui ne vise pas la victoire mais
essaye de se faire sa place au
classement
j'ai commencé à jouer aux échecs se fait
à peu près deux ans je jouais surtout en
ligne mais j'avais envie de deux joueurs
auraient rencontré des adversaires pour
progresser le plus possible
un tournoi qui a lieu depuis 20 ans avec
l'objectif de rassembler tous les
joueurs arrivent les noix passionnés de
l'échiquier